boys
boys we've uh we've been through a lot
together done a pretty good job of
staying out of each other's ways over
the years it's probably for the best you
know hockey players and Hicks haven't
traditionally gotten along well around
here but after everything we've been
through together all the times you've
been there for us and and all the times
we've been there for you we just want to
say
that you have our
respect we respect you you've earned
it we we respect back
you I don't care who are you
again I don't even know what your names
are Dorito head and fun dip face what
I've had more respect for cats who take
dog siiz shits Toto twins look at you
you got a bum chin and a up nose
that bum chin twerk when you jump and
rope you look like Stevie Wonder Drew
Johnny Bravo the bubbalicious boys I
have a hard time believing your mom
wasn't drinking hard bar with you in the
womb your mom loves yab bombs are you're
goes off one morning and say well I
it all up oops I can hit snooze
my whole life so ways piss up a rope
you're a Jolly Rancher and a Honey Nut
Cheerio the Cheeto Chums you ever take a
look in the mirror and think like well
this isn't necessary you dropped as a
child a drop he's an adult gummy
bear boy and the Kit Kat kid how' you
make it out of childhood without
sticking your tongue in a light socket
the peanut butter Brothers hey tip them
over let's see if Fruity Pebbles come
out got a honeycomb and a Cookie Crisp
you're a sour key and a Sun Chip you
like Fruit by the Foot you can Fruit by
the off Riley Jonesy I cooked you
breakfast
this isn't over Jinx sow me a coat cool
I'll feed it to the dogs no not the
maple bacon we're coming Katy cat best
[Music]
bacon